it's the most wonderful time it's the
greatest time of the year Christmas
Christmas has everything you could
possibly need Santa snow presents God
everything is wonderful and of course
let's not forget about the Christmas
specials the Christmas specials are a
time-honored tradition we sit around the
TV and watch as many as we can it's
absolutely fantastic but then there's
that one Christmas special that sneaks
in and spoils everything the one
Christmas special that makes the rest of
the Christmas specials feel bad about
themselves that particular Christmas
special is Robert Dangerfield
well okay it's not entirely
christmas-related but a lot of it does
take place around Christmastime and I
guess it's trying to relate some
Christmas themes but before we talk
about this is probably best to talk
about the person it was based on Rodney
Dangerfield or respect or know the late
comedian was definitely known as a
stand-up stand most comedians get rid of
the idea of just going up and telling
one-liners but Dangerfield was one of
the few stand-ups who kept it go and to
be fair they were pretty funny well I
got no sex life I tried to masturbate I
had a headache
I pay my watch you never went for me the
first time I called her up she told me
come on over there's nobody home I went
over there was nobody home as they play
around so young today very young you
couldn't say they got birth control
pills shaped like Fred Flintstone you
know that's what he was known for his
one life and let's be honest that's when
he was best at in terms of his movie
experience he did have two films that
were big hits back to school on
Caddyshack these movies knew how to use
his one-liners to the film's advantage
this movie does not it's a painful
little train wreck that's entirely based
on just one joke Rodney Dangerfield is a
doll that's it there's literally nothing
else to it and if you think it's like
other movies where you can say the actor
was just a product of the Hollywood
system think again
Riley Dangerfield had everything to do
with this movie he was the producer
handled the screenplay came up with the
idea he even wrote the story with his
pal Harold Ramos how do you think that
process went hey Harold I got this great
idea for kids movie it's me as a dog I
think that would be extraordinarily
dangerous glad you like why Oh
so the big question this movie asks is
Ken's Rodney Dangerfield do anything in
the Kids movie outside of telling
one-liners well not to give away the
ending but no this is Rover Dangerfield
so we open on Las Vegas where our
four-legged friend lives and right from
the very beginning you can see why this
movie isn't going to work I love your
pop-ups
I forgot you a poodle happy first joke I
made and now to even get it
oh so as you can see the dog looks
exactly like Rodney Dangerfield which I
don't think is a good thing I wouldn't
mind too much except that half the time
it looks like his eyes are just staring
off into space like they're animating a
dead wooden puppet or something
Hey look who's in town Carmine's canines
I used to work with them when I was a
pup hey so do I stand upright or walk on
all fours I wrote this movie and even
I'm confused
hey gang how you doing Oh what's flappy
carmine fired him do you remember the
routines well I saw that coming floppy
was dumb how dumb was he I used to walk
backwards in wig his head play so he'd
go hunting done time I taught him how to
sit he forgot how to stand good one then
he going comma hit the trained him that
was something he went right on a paper
the only trouble is calm I was reading
it yeah how many more one liners are
there in this movie Oh God well suppose
it could be worse I mean it is a kid's
film I suppose they could be singing a
song right now it's a dog's life that I
love
Las Vegas is the place for me this is
the place to throw your cares away it's
a dog's life an idol of it all in favor
of skipping this on say fuck off mom I
yeah
so rumor goes backstage to visit his
master what a place
hi Annie big place big place how many
people work here
I don't know what joke point on a four
so rumors master is a showgirl named
Khan which I gotta say is a pretty risky
business doesn't you know that everybody
got AIDS and shit oh you wouldn't forget
my birthday gee I wonder who the villain
is out of all the people in this room I
guess it could be anybody
no but seriously I think is showgirl
number four actually it turns out it's
her boyfriend rocky what a shock as
Rover watches in partake in a shady deal
let's see the fish sorry
that's another one of his phony deals
hiccups it's a setup
let's get outta here wow that is the
most paranoid gang of mobsters I've ever
seen - all their deals go like that I
mean they could be in the middle of a
meeting one guy could be like the cops
it's a setup let's get out of here wait
it's just dog a stupid dog this was your
last chance
small-time curse the day you ever messed
with the easily excitable pussy gang
gonna get you the ruber returns home
only to find that Connie is leaving for
a few weeks and rocky bow bastard is
going to be looking after him rocky Oh
take care of you Rocky
yeah I'd thank you this of course makes
the question why the hell doesn't he
just run I mean the movie shows he has
plenty of time or could he not think up
of a clever one-liner before he could do
it so he tells his Rover in a bag and
proceeds to throw him over the Hoover
Dam what's happening here so what am I
not a lovely this year oh hey hot damn
I'm rolling down the river looks like
I'm all wet I
no no that's not the ending but trust me
you'll wish it was so before all lame
jokes can go to heaven rubber is picked
up by a couple of fishermen before they
can take him to the pound he jumps out
of the car and starts exploring oh I'm
sorry start saying well liners to the
crowd of people that isn't there
no hotels no people no fire hydrants hey
slow down when you're eating like pigs
thanks for making a total stranger feel
like a total stranger please tell me he
gets destroyed by some large piece of
farm equipment
again that's not the real ending but
instead we get you're not gonna believe
this
oh I liner in fact I'm not gonna tell
you the one-liner no I want to just look
at this scenario and tell me the worst
possible joke that you can think up good
luck
well let's look at your answers no
there's no point in looking at the
answers because I know you all got the
same fucking answer so everybody in the
whole goddamn world say on the count of
three what exactly the joke is one two
three I'm fuck you moving fuck you
so he's picked up by a farmer and his
son who want to adopt him
the son is played by the late famous
voice actress Diana hill you may
recognize as Max from goof troop or
Jerry from the Tom and Jerry movie
needless to say she still keeps her
voice and half testicle drum dad stop
the machine we picked up a dog his name
is Rover Platt least that's what it says
I'm gonna stash a critic ty well we
can't keep him we got too many dogs as
it is keep me dead Oh what am I do it
poop oh this guy's been around you know
they make it clear that people can't
understand what the dog is saying so we
then in mind why are the father and son
just staring at each other while the dog
has an epileptic seizure all right Danny
you can keep him Oh take it easy William
so rumor is introduced to all the
incredibly colorful characters on the
farm that is they wouldn't be colorful
they got any screen time but nope we get
to hear Romney recite even more
one-liners okay you cotton balls yeah I
want to pay my doctor with a hog your
little bo-peep days are over what's your
sign well at least he doesn't tell us
the really bad unfunny jokes no no no he
sings those ah give up
okay I don't need to hear about the
bones he's giving to other dogs when I
first saw your face my heart began to
race
you'll fill my soul with ecstasy oh boy
you come here often you know what this
section is so bad I just got spent this
time working on other comedians that
could be bad enemies the gospel would at
least be better than this PC I would
like you die for you I'd give up my red
tie hey you why I would never bark at
you me cos you are my dream come true
alright these are a little crew but I
think they'll still get the idea across
um there's Red Robin Williams uh Andrew
Dice Clay the Chris Rock Eddie lizard oh
and probably the most obvious one Penn &
Teller yeah they're shit but the so
fighters on this fucking crap
so while trying to hit on another dog
called Daisy Roper realize that he's
supposed to be watching the Sheep that
leaves them behind
I did incredibly confusing joke the
sheep ended up in the tree well how did
the Sheep end up in the tree why would
they want to end up in the tree can
somebody explain why the Sheep ended up
in the tree it's my belief that these
sheep are laboring under the
misapprehension that their birds noticed
I do not so much fly as plummet head so
the farmer locks Rover in the cellar
until he can learn to behave himself
it's me Daisy but all that calcia he'll
lock you in here with me hey I hope he
sees you how can you make jokes when
you're locked up like this it's all I
got
haven't you noticed the painfully
written dialogue in this picture by the
way what's up with the lighting all of a
sudden we totally transformed into
Apocalypse Bow Wow done errand-boy
something closely looks besides i missed
a good life come on I'd like to show you
something I know they have bright lights
in the city but do they have anything as
beautiful as this huh
and that was the romance folks pretty
brief huh it's like Dangerfield was all
on board and then halfway through he
decide he hated the idea yeah and then I
decide I'm gonna marry this dog in nah
that's stupid how about I ever say more
1 - hey you think the rain will hurt the
rhubarb God has to go change my name to
Jethro so Rupert decides he doesn't
belong on the farm and tries to run away
I'm nothing but trouble I gotta get out
of here I gotta get out of here that's
not the ending either the Phil provides
some of the opportunities to kill this
character yet they never take advantage
of just go Old Yeller on his ass and get
rid of them already don't give up okay
Daisy do you believe in me okay so Rover
and Daisy have a scene it is absolutely
nothing to leak here Rover and a turkey
have a scene
it ends in fact the next couple of
scenes are like that they just sort of
come and go
it's like drive-by cinema here's the
scene goodbye
here's a scene goodbye on of course this
is all intermixed with the occasional
musical number and let me tell you if
there's ever been a song that had no
reason to be made I need an absolutely
worthless idea for a musical number in a
kid's movie
take a listen to this I'll never do it
on a Christmas tree oh Christmas tree is
safe from me Oh what would Santa think
of me if I did it on a Christmas tree
house oak an oak a splash and heir shall
do it repeat or cherry I'll never do it
on a Christmas tree oh you know whenever
I see such pointlessness shoved into an
animated film I immediately think of all
the trees chopped down to give us this
fucka Saurus in fact I get an image of
tree beard looking over the destruction
and what a pathetic waste of life it is
you missed someone back home don't you
yeah another girl dog
what it's not what you think I mean she
was too young I was too young
it was puppy love my god everyone he
says it's like a slap in the face it
literally feels like every time he tells
a joke the character reaches out of the
screen and smacks me oh boy you heard of
come and get it
this is try and eat it Oh so rumor comes
across a pack of wolves who are after
the farmers turkey the river tries to
stop whew I'm glad we're okay come on
you're okay you're okay come on come on
let's stop harbor we're come on I don't
believe this okay um I'm sure many of
you didn't see this incredibly dark
scene in the movie theater but uh let me
try and recreate what the audience
reaction probably was come on you're
okay you're okay
so it's decided that Rover has to die
for his crimes against the farm
that's about fucking time if he asked me
I may have lived like a dog but I can
die like a man I don't want to leave no
I don't want to go please I didn't do it
how many should I tell you I'm innocent
I did you hear from the governor well at
least he's going out with some dignity I
mean let's face it he could have told
worst jokes Rover I wish we spoke the
same language Oh what you don't speak
bad jokey's but you see I cannot have an
animal on my father killing other
animals this is hard for me Rover if
you've taken a life a life that we were
gonna take anyway um the but um it was a
life yeah what she said
get the title car ready so the Wolves
attack but luckily rubber is on his any
game it teaches them all the lesson that
one's put a three little pigs
I know what you're thinking
you'd rather be a grandma
Wow
what do you think you're dealing with
Little Red Riding Hood Wow
so he compared them to the wolf from the
fairy tales three times
it was Freimuth just telling the exact
same fucking joke three times you know
what it's like it's like someone made a
movie out of there knowing duck hot dog
and I want to shoot that little bastard
just as much as a lot of fucking sugar
no respect at all so I think in the
farmer bad cuz everybody sees that Rover
has saved the day
but Connie sees in a newspaper where
Rover is now and oh wow honey good could
you come over and pick her up and get
there you go yeah that's good family
entertainment so the boy lets Rover know
that Connie is coming to pick him up his
reaction is of course heartbreaking
dad's gonna bring the pickup around and
take it in the air
what an asshole
so just as Connie gets Rover back her
boyfriend comes in and accidentally
reveals that he tried to kill the mutt
this results in a chase scene leading
outside the casino what are you doing
here this is his setup wanna see who the
damn locate you're keeping score at home
kids
that's one turkey and wonder dealer that
get the ax in this family movie yes
somehow the Duck Hunt dog comes out a
lot likes a bitch so as you'd imagine
Rover doesn't like his old environment
and prefers to live back on the farm so
he drops Connie some hands and she
drives him back and lets the farmer
adopt him thus we end with our final
revelation
hey I'm a father of five
hey looks like I did end with a bang and
that's Robert Dangerfield or as I like
to call it unfunny Rodney Dangerfield
stand-up it's basically the same thing
as what celebrities try to write kids
books everybody thinks they can do it
but it takes a lot of talent to do it
right and this film does not do it right
well the animation at times can be
pretty to look at it's not worth the
constant one-liners and extreme lack of
any development it's a clumsy story at
best and not worth all the time and
effort it probably took to make it if
you want to see Robby at his best watch
some of his stand if you want to see him
at his worst
go find this dumbass movie and see why a
bad idea should stay a bad idea
now let's pray to God there's no more
animated comedian knockoff I mean what's
next the nostalgic kitten I'm the
Nostalgia Critic I remember to it on a
Christmas tree oh Christmas tree is safe
from me Oh what would Santa think of me
if I did it on a Christmas tree I'll
never do it on a Christmas tree that's
one thing that you'll never see oh
you'll just have to trust in me I'll
never do it on a Christmas tree I'll so
ghetto girls flash it
I'm turning into a corn dog